c'est vous arnaud mercier bonjour merci
d'être avec nous est professeur en
communications à l'université paris
panthéon assas il s'est entouré dit-on
volodymyr zelensky d'experts en
communication une équipe jeune qui le
conseillent au jour le jour qui est
d'ailleurs resté à ses côtés à kiev
résultat on assiste à une véritable
stratégie de communication politique
extrêmement offensive
oui tout à fait et qui est tout à fait
penser puisque elle est pensée pour
faire en sorte que chaque parlement
puisse en effet s'identifier se projeter
dans la situation ukrainienne il passe
son temps à essayer de mettre en place
des parallèles historiques entre la
situation qui est en train de vivre
l'ukraine et ce que vivent d'autres
peuples dans d'autres situations
historiques et par rapport aux sujets où
il disait votre l'intervenante parlé d'
un parallèle avec les attentats je n'en
suis pas si sûr je pense plutôt qu'il va
faire allusion beaucoup à l'esprit de
résistance à l'invasion allemande
puisque c'est là que le parallèle est
sans doute le plus fort on va là des
références historiques évidemment qui
parle à ses interlocuteurs il parle à la
fois aux élus et en même temps au peuple
on le voit on imagine que les français
vont le suivre c'est ce après midi ce
soir en tout cas
oui tout à fait il ya je crois que il a
réussi à construire un personnage qui
fait qu'il est devenu une espèce d'icône
mondiale est alors bien sûr héroïsé dans
son pays il est le chef de guerre il est
devenu le chef de la résistance
ukrainienne face à de la petite ukraine
face à l'ogre à l'ours le russe on voit
bien toutes les métaphores qui ont été
utilisés pour montrer qu'un peu c'était
david contre goliath et que forcément on
prend plutôt fait et cause pour le petit
contre le gros pour celui qui ne fait
que se défendre contre à celui qui est
qui et qui est injuste et donc en effet
il s'est construit une image de par le
monde où il apparaît comme héroïque et à
soutenir par est par essence même parce
qu'il incarne la résistance de tout un
peuple celui qui fait que se défendre
face à une injuste agression volodymyr
skis c'est un homme qui s'est avant tout
fait connaître dans son dans son pays
par son parcours médiatique un acteur
salue a été d'ailleurs reproché à
plusieurs à plusieurs reprises plus du
tout depuis le début de cette guerre il
est un homme de de l'écran est très à
l'aise c'est une arme pour lui la
communication aujourd'hui 1
c'était indéniable c'est vraiment on
sent bien et quand vous voyez poutine en
plus en comparaison c'est la guerre de
la communication entre les deux
personnages elle est gagnée par zelensky
le soir même de l'invasion puisque il
commence par tout de suite se mettre en
scène avec ses son premier ministre un
certain nombre de chefs des exécutifs et
des principaux des principales fonctions
du pays dans les rues de kiev montrant
qu'il était là qui n'était pas question
de fuir qu'ils allait incarner un esprit
de résistance et il sait très bien
manipuler les réseaux sociaux est
effectivement vous disiez que c'est
entouré de conseillers en vérité il y là
il a une équipe qui est liée à son
équipe de production puisqu'il a été
acteur et producteur de télévision et
qu' il a fait venir à lui un certain
nombre de gens qui iront ce sens de la
mise en scène ce sens de la captation de
l'image de la même manière que l'avait
été en son temps
silvio berlusconi qui avait pareil était
entré dans le jeu politique en faisant
venir à lui une partie des gens qui
étaient liés à ces chaînes
de télévision et qui avait donc qui est
érodée j'allais dire à l'exercice de la
captation de par l'image de l'audience
et de l'intérêt du public et donc là
effectivement il a il allait dire des
années d'avant ce paris vis-à-vis
d'elles a dit poutine il est d'ailleurs
demandé dès le début de la guerre aux
ukrainiens de créer s'il n'en avait pas
déjà des comptes sur les réseaux sociaux
pour documenter un maximum ce conflit
pour apporter des images documenter ce
qui pourrait être utile après pour la
justice internationale il ya une vraie
recherche de visibilité et d'impact
auprès de la population ukrainienne
aussi ah oui là c'est très très clairs
et d'ailleurs finalement grâce aux
réseaux sociaux on peut dire que la
guerre en ukraine est sans doute la
guerre la mieux documentée de l'histoire
récente parce que on a effectivement de
très nombreux ukrainiens qui parce que
ils ont l'habitude ils ont dit aux
comptes ils ont des téléphones mobiles
ils ont un réseau internet qui
fonctionne très bien ils ont les usages
que nous pratiquons nous tous chaque
jour on a l'habitude de prendre une
photo pour témoigner de quelque chose
que l'on a vues qu'on transmet à ses
proches à des amis et c'est qu'on pose
sur ces réseaux donc il ya une espèce de
culture si vous voulez du réseau social
et du témoignage par l'image qui est
déjà très présente et qu'ils ont mis en
en oeuvre pour documenter la guerre y
compris d'ailleurs parfois en essayant
de jouer sur la flamme un peu rond
héroïque de la résistance ordinaire est
par exemple une des images iconiques
finalement de cette guerre c'est les
tracteurs et puisqu'on a vu que de
nombreux fermiers ukrainien quand il y
avait vu un véhicule blindé de l'armée
russe qui était abandonné allez faire
tirer le tirer avec leur tracteur pour
récupérer ce véhicule soit le conserver
quelque part dans un hangar soit le
rendre à l'armée ukrainienne donc
finalement le tracteur est devenu une
des figures de la résistance et
ukrainienne grâce à ces images prises
sur les réseaux sociaux ah non merci on
a parfois le sentiment notamment en
raison de cette cette couverture de la
guerre et par le président et par tous
les maires les élus qui communiquent à
peu près tous de la même manière en se
filmant ans mettant en scène on a
parfois
le sentiment que la frontière entre la
réalité et le cinéma m'a finalement allé
à l'etrat mais ont su ça un peu comme un
comme un feuilleton aujourd'hui
oui alors d'abord il faut dire que ça
correspond à quelque chose qui est très
profondément ancré en nous les
psychiatres parle de pulsion scopique
cette idée que face à des situations
d'urgence défi situation dramatique on a
besoin d'aller voir ego et on a besoin
de voir pour y croire déjà et
souvenez-vous chacun peut le peut en
témoigner nous avons été scotché devant
les images du 11 septembre et où on a il
a fallu qu'on les regarde 2 x 3 x 1 4
fois ses cours tombé pour arriver à
croire que ses coûts' et tour était
tombé et donc quand il ya des situations
dramatiques comme ça on a effectivement
tendance à aller à les regarder parce
qu'on a on a besoin de voir pour y
croire et à partir de là puisqu'on nous
fournit de très nombreuses images sur
les réseaux sociaux que les chaînes
peuvent relayer il ya aussi de temps en
temps quand même aussi des reportages
même si les conditions de tournage sont
plus divisés effectivement il ya une
appétence pour aller regarder pour aller
qu'on essayait de comprendre et de voir
par l'image ce qui se passe mais il faut
se méfier aussi parce que ces images
sont parfois trompeuses alors non merci
une dernière question c'est celle qui
nous intéresse peut-être le plus cette
façon de maintenir la tête de des
ukrainiens hors de l'eau aussi de les
mobiliser on a vu qu'il avait réussi à
créer ce ciment entre les ukrainiens
c'est plus que farouche opposant
aujourd'hui ne jure plus que par lui
est-ce que ça ça peut lui permettre de
gagner la guerre contre la russie demain
on ne peut pas y répondre mais en tout
cas ce que je peux dire c'est que c'est
une condition nécessaire peut-être
qu'elle sera pas suffisante mais elle
est forcément nécessaire et c'est même
d'ailleurs la principale erreur tactique
et stratégique de monsieur poutine
vladimir poutine croit à son discours
quand il dit que l'ukraine n'existe pas
qu'elle ne la reconnaît pas comme une
nation il ne reconnaissait pas non plus
le peuple ukrainien comme une nation
autonome il c'est sa principale erreur
stratégique parce que il ya un esprit de
résistance qui est extrêmement fort chez
les ukrainiens ils n'ont aucune envie de
revenir sous le joug soviétique et le
joug russe et effectivement c'est une
arme très importante c'est ce qui
entretient cet esprit de défense était
plus de résistance
maintenant ce que ça suffira je ne le
sais pas mais en tout cas c'est une
condition nécessaire et elle est bien
présente merci beaucoup arnaud mercier
pour l'éclairage